you have to live on less than you make
and you have to have a plan and you have
to be intentional I meet people that
make thirty thousand dollars a year that
save money I mean people make a hundred
thirty thousand dollars a year couldn't
save money if they had to
it hasn't got anything to do with the
income it's got to do with you freaking
controlling the person in your mirror
it's you deciding I'm going to be a
grown-up I'm going to be an adult
and that's if you're 52 you're 22 or
you're 12.
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
everybody's all worried about
everybody's feelings these days I'm not
worried about your feelings I make a
living hurting your feelings
don't give a crap about your feelings
let me tell you what feels good not
having any dead gun payments so what
feels good having a pile of money in the
bank that feels good being wealthy
enough to be take your eyes off yourself
and not be a dad blame self-centered and
actually be generous